fantastische Emotionen also ich muss
ehrlich gestehen ich habe jetzt
überhaupt einmal mindestens zwei Monate
gebraucht das alles für mich persönlich
zu verarbeiten
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen beim Sport Podcast
des österreichischen Bundesheers heute
zu Gast Zugführer Markus Fuchs herzlich
willkommen der schnellste Österreicher
hat bei mir hier beim Platz genommen Leo
Markus was für eine Saison für dich oder
ja es war definitiv eine richtig geile
Saison für mich ähm die beste die ich
bisher gehabt habe und ja ich konnte
viele Träume und der Folge heuer
umsetzen für dich sehr lange gekämpft
habe und zwar mich natürlich riesig wir
werden auch gleiche über diese Folge
reden und alles was du hinbekommen hast
aber wenn du zurückblickst auf den
Anfang der letzten Saison hättest du
glaubst dass es mein Jahr das wird so
aufgehen ja ich habe schon bisschen
damit reguliert also ich habe sehr lange
dafür gearbeitet und man muss sagen ich
habe natürlich die Jahre davor sehr viel
verändert in meinem Alltag ich habe mir
eine neue Trainingsgruppe im Ausland
gesucht und habe viel verändert und es
hat sich eben schon ein bisschen
angefahren ich habe dann diese coolen es
bekommen war komplett frei locker hat
sich im vor allen Dingen schon über die
Trainingslager und in den Training sind
wir abgezeichnet dass ich da halt
wirklich in eine super Form komme und
von dem her war das dann für mich
eigentlich gar nicht so die riesen
Überraschung ja großartiger Einstieg
schon gehabt und dann wollte ich einfach
nur noch mehr und das Meer das hast du
dann unter anderem auch geschafft mit
der Einstellung des österreichischen
Rekordes über die 100 Meter das ist ja
die königsdiszipline bis zu 10 15
gelaufen der Weg bis dorthin war
schwierig das ist jetzt ein bisschen
anklingen lassen was hast du denn alles
machen müssen damit auch diese 10 15
kommst puh ja wie gesagt das war ein
sehr steiniger Weg also ich habe eben
vor ein paar Jahren gemerkt dass ich
irgendwann einen Punkt anstehe wo es für
mich persönlich einfach nicht mehr
weiter geht wusste auch nicht ganz wie
ich mich da jetzt weiterentwickeln soll
und habe mich hingesetzt und mir selbst
einfach einmal also lädt gedacht okay
was brauche ich einfach dass ich diesen
österreichischen Rekord oder was brauche
ich damit zu Olympischen Spielen kann
bin ich gegangen haben ein bisschen Zeit
genommen und haben dann für mich einfach
selber einmal das optimale also für mich
persönlich optimale Team zusammen
erstellt und ja wie gesagt das ist das
eine ist ein ins andere alle Zahnräder
zusammengespielt und ja daraus ist dann
eben so eine Leistung entstanden sage
ich jetzt mal als du auf die Anzeige
geschaut hast beim Rekord und gesehen
hast dass du diese Zeit geschafft hast
was ist da durch Dich gegangen das
fantastische Emotionen also ich muss
ehrlich gestehen ich habe jetzt
überhaupt einmal mindestens zwei Monate
gebraucht das alles für mich persönlich
zu verarbeiten weil mir das natürlich
einfach umso mehr bedeutet weil ich weiß
was ich eigentlich wirklich selbst aufge
opfert habe dafür und wie viel ich
investiert habe und deswegen ist es für
mich halt wirklich so ein emotionaler
Meilenstein noch gewesen und ja ist
natürlich großartig ich ja ich freue
mich natürlich riesig drüber und ja
trotzdem ist es natürlich so dass ich
noch immer nicht ganz zufrieden bin weil
ich einfach weiß dass viel mehr
schlummert und ja in den nächsten Jahren
reicht dafür sorgen dass es danach
umsetzbar wird und dass das dann in dem
Sinne deinen alleine
auf jeden Fall vor also wie gesagt mein
Ziel oder also ich sage immer so ich
setze mir gern Ziele aber ich bin auch
ein Träumer und ich habe das immer schon
so gehabt also wir haben es sehr sehr
hohe Ziele gesteckt und irgendwie
probiert dann an diese Ziele zu kommen
und diese umzusetzen und ja wie gesagt
mein nächster kleiner Traum ist
natürlich schon wovon jeder träumt mal
zu den Olympischen Spielen zu kommen auf
der bin ich sicher jetzt auf einem sehr
guten Weg und das nächste Thema wird
natürlich sein es gibt es diese 10,00
Sekunden ich weiß nicht ob man dann
zufrieden wäre 10,00 Sekunden läuft
deswegen ist so eine kleine Zahl in
meinem Hinterkopf natürlich die 9,99 ist
das auch wirklich so eine so ein eine
eine Schwelle die man übersteigen möchte
in seiner Karriere ja ich muss natürlich
sagen es gibt nicht so viele super zehn
Sprinter da überhaupt in Europa und ich
gehöre jetzt mit meinen 10 15 80 schon
zu den schnellsten Europäern ja das ist
einfach ein persönliches Ziel weil
irgendwo muss man ja auch ähm
realistisch bleiben man kann das jetzt
auch nicht so vergleichen mit den Welt
Topstars bringt dann das ist dann doch
noch mal ein großen Unterschied zu mir
ja wie gesagt ich fokussiere mich da
eher so auf diesen europäischen Bereich
und probiert dass ich da irgendwann in
den nächsten anderen mal fahren
mitmischen kann und ich bin mir eben
auch sicher dass ich das Zeug dazu habe
bis auf jeden Fall auf dem besten Weg
dorthin aber wie hat dieser Weg denn
begonnen man sagt laufen sie in dem
Sinne dass natürlichste aber auf diesem
Niveau auch das hochkomplexeste was
wahrscheinlich finden kann es geht um
100 das ist wahnsinnig eng beieinander
und es ist eine weltsportart wie bist du
zum Laufen gekommen prinzipiell
eigentlich ganz simpel wie
wahrscheinlich alle viele andere Kinder
zu ihren Sportarten kommen was bei mir
auch so meine Eltern haben mich von
Anfang an also muss ich einen großen
Dank aussprechen natürlich mal familiär
die Eltern haben mich immer schon
unterstützt und habe mich als kleines
Kind haben sie mich einfach viel
ausprobieren lassen ich habe am Anfang
mal ein bisschen Kinderturnen gemacht
habe dann noch Tennis gespielt Handball
ausprobiert und ja wie gesagt mir das
alles sehr viel Spaß gemacht aber es war
dann irgendwie so dass wir dass ich beim
Kinderturnen hat mich dann der
tourenlehrer darf auf gemacht das ist in
der Südstadt einen Leichtathletik Verein
gibt und ich soll dort mal vorbeischauen
weil ich bin schnell und ja wie gesagt
ich mir hat das immer riesen Spaß
gemacht dass du Kinder Kinder Mehrkämpfe
kinderwettkämpfe und ich bin dann
einfach dort hängen geblieben ja im
übergangsalter dann wo es wirklich also
wo du dann von von verschiedenen
Disziplinen die ich dann langsam
fokussieren muss hat mich dann meine
ehemalige also frühere Trainerin im
geschnappt und sagt so entscheide dich
jetzt mal langsam ich habe dann gesagt
natürlich will ich auf dem Sprint gehen
weil schnell war ich Gott sei Dank immer
schon und so bin ich dann immer dabei
geblieben und ja wie gesagt also viel
hat sich seitdem nicht verändert ich bin
Gott sei Dank noch immer schnell und ja
wie gesagt das einzige was ich dann im
Laufe der Zeit verändert hat waren dann
eigentlich nur meine Trainingspartner
Trainingsgruppe Trainer und ja die
weiteren Schritte war die damals schon
bewusst dass die 100 Meter so hart sind
sind eine ganz ganz kurze Disziplin aber
da liegt alles so eng beieinander weil
das als Kind bewusst dass die
Königsdisziplin ist ja natürlich ehrlich
also das war mir von klein auf bewusst
weil im Endeffekt bei uns geht es
einfach darum wer so schnellste es ist
eigentlich komplett simpel wenn man das
jetzt so sieht und das ist das Kind
natürlich auch bewusst also bei mir war
es immer so ich bin extrem ehrgeizig und
ich wollte natürlich immer gewinnen oder
es ist natürlich wie bei allen anderen
Sportlern auch du kannst nicht immer
gewinnen oder musst einfach den Weg
finden wie kann ich gewinnen das war bei
mir einfach irgendwie auch wichtig für
diesen Anrath und ja wie gesagt ich bin
extremer Jacke Hetzler und habe mich
immer weiter gekämpft und ja du bist in
Österreich mit Abstand der schnellste
das macht es aber wahrscheinlich auch
schwer die Vorbereitung des Training so
zu gestalten er macht sie auch viel mit
Trainingspartner du kannst nicht nur
alleine trainieren
mit welchen Herausforderungen warst du
da so konfrontiert in deiner Karriere
besetzt ja ich muss sagen ich bin
natürlich der schnellste aber vom
Trainings äh Effekt macht das jetzt
nicht unbedingt viel aus also zumindest
in meiner Person weil mir geht's also
wenn ich jetzt sonst Training denke
geht's bei mir nicht immer nur um ich
muss jetzt schneller sein als mein
Trainingskollege oder mein train
Arbeitskollege darf auch mal schneller
sein als ich also so ist es nicht
wichtig ist sicher nur dass du also in
meinem Falle dass ich Personen finde mit
denen ich einfach gut arbeiten kann und
vor allem was auch sicher zählt einfach
Spaß zu haben es ist wie im normalen
Beruf oder im Alltag also wenn du vorher
dann der Sache hast die du tust dann
wirst du dich immer also in meiner
Meinung nach immer entwickeln und immer
Weiterkommen also wie gesagt das sollte
überhaupt kein Problem darstellen du
hast auf jeden Fall jetzt deine
sportliche Trainingsgruppe in der
Schweiz gefunden was so funktioniert
dort für dich so optimal was passt gut
ich muss sagen es passt einfach alles
optimal und das war auch der Grund warum
ich eben ins Ausland gegangen bin ja ich
habe es vorher schon angesprochen ich
habe mich hier in Österreich einfach
nicht mehr so weit entwickelt wie ich
mir das persönlich gewünscht habe und
das war dann der ausschlaggebende Punkt
warum ich für mich selber gesagt habe
okay ich möchte ins Ausland gehen weil
ich einfach schon ja wie gesagt ich
schaue mich auch um ich arbeite
natürlich nur für mich aber ich sehe
immer bei anderen Sportlern wie arbeiten
die was tun die wie werden sie besser
ist für mich natürlich trotzdem sehr
interessant und ich habe einfach sehr
sehr vielen jetzt Leistungsträgern da in
Österreich gesehen sie wagen den Sprung
ins Ausland und entwickeln sich weiter
jetzt wo ich natürlich selbst gemacht
habe weiß ich genau wovon viel einfach
sprechen weil es geht einfach ja nicht
nur um die Entfaltung der sportlichen
Leistung sondern einfach wirklich diese
menschliche Entwicklung und dieses
weiter voran kommen und das hat mir
einfach sozusagen wenn man das schön
sagen möchte den Horizont irgendwie
geöffnet und ja es ist einfach es ist
unglaublich für mich wenn ich da in die
Schweiz darf also ich sehe das natürlich
als Ehre dass mich der Schweizer Verband
da auch wirklich mit unterstützt nicht
oder österreichische Verband sondern es
ist eben über mich eine entstandene
Kooperation auch zum Schweizer verwandt
weil es ist nicht selbstverständlich
dass die Ausländer wenn man das jetzt so
sagen kann ich einfach aufnehmen und
sagen hey cool wir haben jetzt einen
Ausland da und der darf jetzt mitnehmen
also ist für mich wirklich nicht
selbstverständlich und für mich eine
sehr große Ehre und vor allem man sieht
auch in der Leichtathletik ist die
Schweiz jetzt gerade im springt und auch
in der Leichtathletik allgemein ein Land
der sich in Europa mächtig entwickelt
hat sieht man auch einen internationalen
Leistungen und Medaillen würdest du
sagen dass deine Leistung deine 10-15 da
auch diese Türen leichter geöffnet haben
auch ermöglicht haben auch beschriebene
auf bei anderen Wettkämpfen bei größeren
Wettkämpfen mit dabei zu sein ja auf
jeden Fall also diese 10 15 sind
wirklich ein Statement auch europaweit
ich habe so schon gemerkt ich werde
plötzlich zu internationalen Wettkämpfe
eingeladen und bei uns funktioniert das
ja noch auf so einem Einladungssystem
dadurch dass wir teilweise wirklich nur
bis zu 16 Plätze pro Wettkampf für ganz
Europa zum Beispiel haben ist es nicht
so einfach in die Klasse Meetings
reinzukommen da braucht man einfach
schnelle Zeiten wichtig für mich wird in
der Zukunft sein dass ich diese
schnellen Zeiten auch auf wirklich
solche also auf größere Ebene dann auch
präsentieren kann und nicht nur hier in
in Österreich Deutschland und in der
Schweiz das heißt auch bei den großen
Wettkämpfen dann auch diese Performance
abrufen weil dafür wirst du dann in dem
Sinne auch eingeladen warum würdest du
sagen ist das für den Nachwuchs im
Standbereich in Österreich nicht so
leicht oder nicht so einfach in diese
Top-Klasse Leistungen zu kommen
ja das ist eine ganz ganz schwierige
Frage für mich
jetzt kurz überlegen also wenn der Name
ist so eine gute Frage habe ich schon
lange nicht mehr gestellt bekommen
ich sehe so ich bin jetzt gar nicht so
involviert in unserer Nachwuchs muss ich
auch ehrlich zugeben aber was ich immer
wieder mitbekomme ist dass wir einfach
vor allem Mädchen
[Musik]
Nachwuchs bekommen aber keine männlichen
Nachwuchs und auch die Dichte im
Nachwuchs einfach viel zu gering ist
also wir haben einfach viel zu weniger
viel zu wenig Athleten und Athletinnen
Nachwuchs dass wir dann wirklich aus
seiner breiten Masse sozusagen diese
diese Top-Stars wenn man so schön sagen
möchte äh Formen könnte also uns fehlen
einfach die Leute ich denke mir es wäre
schön und das hat man sich auch über
Corona gemerkt also man müsste man
müsste hier die Kinder und Leute einfach
bisschen wieder in diese Richtung
Bewegungsdrang fast ein bisschen darüber
schwängern damit sich da unten auch mal
was tut weil wenn von unten nicht
nachkommt wird sondern immer schwieriger
dass man oben an der spreche ich halt
eben auf internationaler Ebene irgendwas
hinaus bekommt ja glaubst auch dass
vielleicht die Konkurrenz vom Fußball
das große weil deine Qualitäten sind
auch das was dem Fußball zum Beispiel
gesucht wurde schnelle Sprinter sie
schnell sind dass da die Kids dann
vielleicht eher wenn sie schnell sind
beim Fußball landen oder in anderen
Sportarten weil sie in dem Sinne das was
du mitbringst das ist ja auch die Basis
in vielen anderen Sportarten
so so kritisch habe ich das jetzt noch
gar nicht gesehen aber ja es gibt sicher
also ich bin mir sicher wir haben es
sehr ein Thema was ich eben immer
bisschen noch leidig finde also Fußball
und Leichtathletik es sind eben zwei
ganz verschiedene Sportarten man kann so
überhaupt nicht vergleichen
ja wie gesagt aber es gibt doch sicher
Fußballer die sehr schnell sehen also es
lässt sich überhaupt nicht abstreiten
ich muss sagen auch ein ehemaliger
Trainings Kollege von mir ist auch
damals aber hat den anderen Weg ist
Switch sozusagen Fußball in die
Leichtathletik ist gar nicht sein das
ist jetzt kein Ausnahmefall also gibt es
immer wieder das wäre ein paar Fußballer
sozusagen abwerben können aber ja
prinzipiell ich denke einfach auch es
ich glaube es liegt überhaupt daran dass
sie leicht erledigen in Österreich
einfach noch nicht dieses Statement
dieses Statement einer wirklich
eleganten schönen und eindrucksvollen
Sportart muss ich sagen weil es ist dann
doch schon so wenn jetzt neue Leute neue
Fans oder so ins Stadion bei uns kommen
das ist eine spezielle Atmosphäre und
jeder der man in einer Leichtathletik
zuschauen war weiß einfach wie wie geil
diese Sportart ist also wirklich ja da
kann man glaube ich viel mitnehmen sage
ich jetzt nicht nur weil ich selber
leichter lädt bin sondern ja weil es
einfach auch den Leuten rundherum
einfach wirklich taugt ich glaube dass
die obermeisterschaft in München da auch
dieses Gefühl bei vielen Vektor das war
jetzt in der Nähe der Heimat sehr viele
haben dort zugeschaut und haben das
glaube ich gut mitgenommen was das sagst
du warum Andreas Berger aus dem Jahr
1998 nicht früher schon gebrochen wurde
von irgendjemanden vor dir
das kann ich mir auch nicht erklären
weil ich vielleicht eben vielleicht aus
dem Grund weil noch niemand darauf
gekommen ist wie man einfach richtig auf
so eine Zeit hin aber wartet also das
kann ich mir schon ein bisschen erklären
weil wie gesagt ich habe bis jetzt also
bis vor zwei Jahren hätte ich jetzt auch
nicht ich habe immer gesagt ich will ich
will ich will ich möchte dorthin aber
ich wusste nicht wie und ich glaube das
ist einfach dieser Ansatz den man den
wir einfach unter was ich auch probiere
also ich bin dann offener Mensch und
wenn wenn irgendjemand egal auch aus
anderen Sportarten Fragen hat hey wie
kann ich schneller werden oder was
könnte ich tun ich würde jedem helfen
also ist überhaupt kein Problem wenn wir
dann mal Leute schreiben oder mich
fragen ich glaube schon dass ich
mittlerweile durch das Ganze durch
dieses ganze Reisen und diese
Auslandsaufenthalte und diese ja einfach
sehr viel gelernt habe was ich auch
selber als lädt einfach schon
weitergeben könnte es ist mir jetzt noch
nicht so oft passiert aber immer wieder
fragen mich auch zum Beispiel Fußballer
oder aus der anderen Sportarten hey ich
finde das cool ähm ich würde gerne ein
bisschen was wissen ja dann helfe ich
gerne mal er könnte das vorstellen dass
du Trainer wirst und den nach wichtigste
ganz schnell bei einem wachsigen ich
glaube jetzt zum Beispiel könnte ich es
mir noch überhaupt nicht vorstellen weil
ich selber noch aktiver Athlet bin aber
ja wie gesagt ich sage mal so ich lasse
mir meine Zukunft immer offen ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht wo es mir
nachher wo es mich nachher später mal
hinziehen wird weil ich mir das eben ich
lebe ihm hier und jetzt das war immer
schon so ähm ich ich habe noch keine
Pläne geschmiedet wo es dann mal
weitergeht vielleicht wäre ich auch mal
irgendwie Coach oder oder ja wie gesagt
mal kann ich jetzt noch nicht sagen du
hast ja noch viel zum Laufen vor dir ich
werde immer wieder gefragt warum ich so
viel Turniere weil ich viel mehr nur 100
m und 200 m und wenn ich dann den Leuten
sage dass ich Umfänge habe von 10 km am
Tag die ich schwimmen muss dann
verstehen sie es nicht weil ich ja eh
nur einfach auf 100 Meter schnell sein
muss also ich könnte dauernd irgendwie
100 da schwimmen so funktioniert das
Schlimme nicht aber wie ist das weil ich
eine Leichtathletik du läufst in dem
Sinne 100 Meter in der Halle manchmal 60
Meter wie kann man sich da Training bei
dir vorstellen abholen im Endeffekt hört
sich jetzt vielleicht eine sim-plan aber
ich habe einfach meine vier läuferischen
Einheiten in der Woche und meine zwei
bis drei Zimmer einhalten also im
Kraftraum und ja wie gesagt das Spielen
einfach sehr viele Faktoren bei uns auch
zusammen es ist jetzt kein Geheimnis
dass die dass die der Sprint über die
Kraft reguliert wird die Kraftkomponente
ist genauso wichtig wie das laufen und
im Endeffekt gilt es einfach darum
genau diesen Ausgleich zu finden wie
viel laufe ich wie viel muss ich Kraft
trainieren und wenn man das alles
richtig gestaltet dann kommen einfach
gute Leistungen dabei raus und ist auch
ein hochtechnischer Sport also ja ähm
merkst du ein Unterschied zwischen einem
Lauf und dann machst du noch einen und
du sagst alle anderen viel besser und
ich würde wahrscheinlich nur schauen und
sagen das ist alles gleich da läuft
einfach schnell ja also bei mir ist es
ist dieser Sport ist so hoch sensibel
dass ich wirklich jede 100er spüren kann
also wenn man das jetzt z.B im Training
her nimmt da haben wir natürlich werden
so leute wenn ich jetzt Intervall läuft
z.B wird wahrscheinlich jedem was sagen
habe dann wird es wirklich auf die
Zehntel ausgelegt und ich schaffe es
dann einfach wirklich vom Gefühl her das
ist einfach schon so drinnen in mir
selbst das ist dann wirklich vom Gefühl
scharf einfach genau die Zehntel zu
treffen vielleicht plus minus eine
Zehntel aber in einem in einem so
kleinen Bereich ja weil der Sport
einfach so hoch sensibel ist darfst Du
einfach wirklich auch im Trainings
Aufbau und sonst wo einfach gar keine
Fehler erlauben ne ist es auch wichtig
dass du dieses gespürst dass du einfach
weißt wie ist mein Körper wie laufe ich
jetzt wo bin ich jetzt verstehe ich
jetzt das ist ganz wichtig also vor
allem als Sprinter nicht nur als
Sprinter selbst sondern auch als Trainer
das ist eben diese die Athleten Trainer
Kombi es müssen einfach beide dieses
Gefühl haben weil der also der Trainer
muss ich einfach genauso in dich rein
versetzen können und andersrum damit du
damit einfach diese das Training perfekt
regulieren kannst weil sonst ja endet
das Ganze leider in einem Chaos und das
soll natürlich nicht passieren die
Laufbahn in Paris das ist wahrscheinlich
die hängt irgendwo bei dir daheim oder
jeden Tag was wird das brauchen für ein
erfolgreich Olympia-Qualifikation das
ist eine weltsportart das heißt über 100
Nationen die dabei sind in der
Leichtathletik auch im Laufen in dem
Sinne braucht es nicht viel um Läufer zu
produzieren außer natürlich viel Geduld
aber die Bedingungen sind so da dass die
Konkurrenz halt wahnsinnig hoch ist wie
schaut den Weg aus nach Paris ja also
ich sage mal
es wird nicht für viel mehr brauchen als
was ich jetzt liefern konnte ich werde
mich sicher in dem Bereich wenn ich mich
in den Bereich von den Zeiten und
ergeben müssen in denen ich mich jetzt
in dem Jahr abgespielt habe irgendwo
befindet in den nächsten ein bis zwei
Jahren schaut sehr sehr gut aus dass ich
mich qualifizieren werde ich sag's immer
so das Wichtigste am Sport generell ist
einfach die Gesundheit hat unter der
fangt das ganze einfach an also gesund
bleiben ist das A und O und dann ergibt
sich eh alles von alleine wenn die
Trainings gut laufen laufen die
Wettkämpfen gut und ja von dem her um
das Ganze vielleicht ein bisschen zu
vereinfachen ich werde einfach viele
gute schnelle Wettkämpfe machen und dann
hoffen dass es sich mit der Welt
eigentlich Qualifikation ausgeht die von
der Variante wäre die diese 10,0
Sekunden zu knacken wo aber die
Weltrangliste Qualifikation im Moment
noch ein bisschen realistischer wäre ja
so ehrlich müssen wir sein und das ist
die Gesundheit angesprochen da gehört
natürlich auch
Verletzungsprophylaxe dazu als du früher
noch in der Südstadt
öfters vom Training warst und nicht aus
dem Schwimmbad geschaut habe habe ich
gemerkt dass Ihr Euch ewig lang aufwärmt
weil natürlich so ein sonnensprung
wahnsinnige Kräfte auf die Muskeln
bedeutet ist das wirklich so dass man da
wirklich fast schon länger aufwärmt als
den praktischen Trainingsreiz dann
eigentlich setzt ja also ich sage mal
länger auf wenn man seine Sache es geht
einfach darum ja wenn man von Gesundheit
sprechen natürlich das das Aufwärmen ist
ganz wichtig aber worum es wirklich geht
ist einfach dieses rundherum also vor
allem Physiotherapie Massage von mir als
wenn der Schweiz sind da gehe ich
natürlich auch zum kiropraktiker oder
einen Osteopathen diese ganzen Dinge
sind wirklich wichtig weil ja man muss
sich einfach immer wohl fühlen es kann
man mal sagen dass man zum Beispiel in
der früh aufsteht und irgendwas zwickt
ja ist vielleicht dann beim Sprint wo du
wirklich immer 100% geben muss dann
nicht die optimale Grundstellung für für
ein Training muss man zum Beispiel mal
vor dem Training dann spontan sagen hey
okay ich muss mal schauen muss noch mal
zum Physio gehen mich bisschen
einrichten lassen ein bisschen
auflockern und dann komme ich erst ins
drehen also dann beginnt das Training
also sozusagen worauf ich hinaus will
ich eigentlich es muss davor schon alles
passen damit ich überhaupt ein gutes
Training starten kann und dann kann ich
eben mit so einem aufwärmen oder
sonstigen beginnen aber das ist doch
dass du flexibel genug sein musst oder
also dass du sagst ich höre heute auf
mich und auch wieder Trainingsplan sagt
das wäre zu tun aber es hat keinen Sinn
dann jetzt das zu machen weil ich damit
vielleicht riskiere dass ich irgendwas
kaputt macht
ich habe oftmals seine Momenten sehr mit
mir gekämpft dass ich z.B Training
reduziere oder was anderes mache weil
ich mir die Ziele gesetzt habe das
erreichen möchte wie gehst Du in solchen
Situationen um das langfristige Ziel zu
erreichen und eben nicht nur kurzfristig
zu sein also wie gesagt ich bin ja sehr
speziell und das war auch der Grund
warum ich mich sozusagen als einzelner
jetzt irgendwo Medizin bewegt habe
um meine Ziele zu erreichen es war so
dass ich mir einfach mein komplettes
Teams extra so zusammengestellt habe
also wenn wir von Flexibilität sprechen
ich bin einfach sehr sensibel sehr
emotional und ich brauche einfach Leute
um mich herum die genauso denken und
arbeiten wie ich weil nur so komme ich
zu meinen Leistungen und das habe ich
mir einfach selber vor zwei Jahren
eingestanden und haben einfach daran
begonnen in dieser Baustelle sozusagen
dich selbst hatte zu arbeiten und einen
nach anderen immer ein Boot zu holen
sozusagen und wie gesagt jetzt ist es so
ich fühle mich absolut sicher und ich
kann wirklich also ich habe so viel Spaß
wie noch nie ich muss auch sagen ich
hatte zwei zwei Jahren einfach wirklich
so viel Spaß im Training und ja dadurch
und durch die ganzen Leute die mich da
runter und unterstützen das ist nicht
nur eine Einzelarbeit sozusagen einfach
Teamwork also muss man auch dazu sagen
Flexibilität dadurch dass ich alleine
bin bin ich natürlich sehr flexibel ich
habe hier natürlich auch den Dominik
Distelberger ist für mich eine mega mega
wichtiger Mensch einfach der mir auch
durch diese ganzen auch durch die
schweren Zeiten immer auch nicht
vergessen darf sehr viel durchgeholfen
hat und ja ich bin so flexibel wie er
ist also er unterstützt mich da im
Training Gott sei Dank steht mit mir
wirklich jeden Tag am Platz wenn ich
hier in Österreich bin weil wenn ich in
der Schweiz bin habe ich dort natürlich
mein Team und wie gesagt dort haben wir
dann strikte Trainingszeiten wo ich
natürlich dann nicht sage Leute ich
komme am Vormittag hier drin jetzt am
Nachmittag da ist natürlich dann
wirklich das Team an vorderer Stelle das
Dominik Distelberger Winter 10 Kämpfer
langjähriger Hersteller auch und habe
ich auch öfters gemeinsam trainieren
gesehen dass der Spaß erwähnt und ich
möchte das wirklich irgendwie
hervorheben weil ich das auch beobachtet
habe so repräsentativ waren für mich die
Fotos von der sportlounge in
Niederösterreich wurde den dritten Platz
gemacht hast bei mir das Rechnen
Sportler des Jahres hinter benical und
Felix und man hat wirklich das Gefühl du
genießt das also doch das Sport wirklich
super läuft aber auch dass du die
Möglichkeit hast jetzt deine Geschichte
zu erzählen mit gespart etwas zu
bewirken also man merkte dann Spaß an
ist das so ja auf jeden Fall also Spaß
habe ich immer schon gehabt und wie
gesagt ich trag das auch gerne nach
außen also alles was ich erlebe und
alles was ich leiste und so ich bin
immer sehr dankbar wenn einfach so viele
Leute also so viele Leute wie möglich
involviert werden in das ganze weil ich
denke mal natürlich mache ich den Sport
mache ich natürlich nur für mich und nur
meine Ziele und Träume
zu zu erreichen aber ich denke man kann
auch irgendwas zurückgeben und irgendwas
weitergeben das war immer schon dieses
Geben und Nehmen ist für mich ein ganz
wichtiges Thema einfach und ja also ich
freue mich und genieße das wenn ich
einfach auch viele Leute involvieren
darf und ja wie gesagt ich bin ein
bisschen speziell vielleicht und aber im
Endeffekt geht es mir trotzdem genauso
mein Spaß wie hoffentlich vielen anderen
Spaß danach auch speziell erfolgreich
auf jeden Fall lieber Markus zum
Abschluss darfst du auf ein paar Fragen
noch Antworten mir macht Laufen Spaß
weil
einfach geil ist einfach geil das Laufen
sehr gut als Kind wollte ich immer schon
schnell werden schnell werden schnell
warst du auf jeden Fall wäre ich kein
Läufer dann wäre ich American Football
Spieler echt ist das etwas ja also ich
schaue sehr gerne Fernsehen ist
natürlich bisschen rau die Sport also
ich glaube wenn ich mit meiner jetzigen
Statur ich muss das hier noch bisschen
mehr ins Team gehen wenn ich mich da
jetzt am Platz stellen würde würden
nämlich umnähen aber ja ist sicher ein
Sport den man sich sehr gut anschauen
kann und der auch Spaß macht und
Zuschauen das ist ich vergleiche das
immer gerne ein bisschen Anliegen doch
einen Sprint weil das doch ja sehr
schnell sehr athletisch und ja einfach
ein cooler Sport mit einer
Geschwindigkeit wärst du auf jeden Fall
gut einzusetzen in einem Team aber
sicher auch Talente die dich nicht beim
schnell werden schneller machen mein
unnützes Talent ist
ich kann nicht aufhören zu reden wenn
ich meine Fahrt komme
nicht schlecht vor allem in meiner
Branche also vielleicht wächst dass du
dann auch irgendwann einmal die Seiten
meine schmerzhafteste Wettkampf
Erfahrung
ich muss sagen das beläuft sich gar
nicht auf eine sondern ich habe schon
öfters bei Großereignissen leider nicht
das bringen können was ich eigentlich
zeigen wollte und auch wenn es nach
außen vielleicht manchmal lustig wirkt
und ich mich zusammenreißt schmerzt mich
dass jedes Mal wenn ich dann nicht das
vorgesetzte Ziel erreichen kann und das
ist bis jetzt nicht nur einmal passiert
dann bleiben wir gleich auch auf
positiven Seite meine schönste Wettkampf
Erfahrung also muss ich sagen ist sind
zwei weil ich die gleichsetzen möchte
das ist einerseits natürlich der
österreichische Rekord heuer also der
mir wie immer vorher wahrscheinlich
gemerkt sehr sehr viel bedeutet und die
andere ist natürlich trotz allem auch
wenn ich dort z.B es war die
schmerzhafteste aber auch die schönste
in München die Europameisterschaft weil
ich dort so viel mitnehmen konnte und
ich und ich mir sicher bin dass sie dort
so viel gelernt hat dass ich dann
nächstes Mal noch besser umsetzen kann
ich träume von
einer Olympia Qualifikation dafür
wünschen wir dir auf jeden Fall viel
Erfolg wir träumen mit dir und sind aber
davon überzeugt dass es kein Traum
bleibt sondern Realität werden jetzt
danke danke
wir hatten den schnellsten Mann
Österreicher zum Sportverband wir freuen
uns wenn ihr auch beim nächsten Mal
wieder mit dabei seid bis dann
[Applaus]